سريع ومريح ولا يغسل يختفي هذا الطبق
سريعا لكن البلاستيك يبقى لمده طويله جدا
الان من المقرر يحظر الاطباق وادوات
المائده ذات الاستخدام الواحد في انجلترا
لكن البداء الى قد تكون مكلفه
اخبرك بما ان بصراحه سيغلق المزيد من
المحلات
وراء هذه القضيه برغمتها هناك حقيقه صارخه
ادوات المائده الخشبيه يمكن ان تتحلل في
غضون عامين بالنسبه للبلاستيك يمكن ان
يستغرق الامر مئه عام وفقا لوزاره البيئه
والغذاء والشؤون الريفيه في انجلترا
يستخدم مليار طبق بلاستيكي واكثر من اربعه
مليارات قطعه من ادوات المائده ذات
الاستخدام الواحد لمره واحده سنويا في
انجلترا ومع ذلك يعاد تدوير نحو عشره في
المئه فقط وتندرج الخطوه ضمن الخطه
البيئيه على مدار ربع قرن للقضاء على
التلوث البلاستيكي بحلول عام
2000242 لكن التحول كامله قد يكلف القطاع
ما يقدر بنحو 90 مليون جنيه استرليني
سنويا
في سوق الطعام هذا هناك الكثير من
البلاستيك المستخدم يشمل الحظر مجموعه من
الادوات المتعلقه بالطعام والشراب الجاهز
لكننا يقولون ان هذا غير كافي
مملكه المتحده مسؤوليه حقيقيه لاصلاح ازمه
البلاستيك هذه ويبدو الامر كما لو اننا
نتغاضى عن حدود مشكله كبيره هنا بمجرد حظر
بعض القطع المختلفه
والمطاعم وليس على المواد البلاستيكيه
المستخدمه في تغليف الاطعمه والمشروبات
المباعه في محلات السوبر ماركت تقول
الحكومه انها تعمل على خطه المنفصله لبائع
التجزئها هؤلاء لتغطيه تكلفه التخلص من
البلاستيك 2024